Narrator: These the Sharks.
They have achieved
incredible success
as entrepreneurs and investors
in multiple sectors.
[ All cheering ]
They all came
from humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Now they are investing
in entrepreneurs' dreams.
We're taking toys
to a place
that they've
never gone before.
This is
a trillion‐dollar market.
Trillion?
Guys, something's not
adding up for me, though.
Do you want want to do
a deal with Kevin?
There's a reason I'm here.
There's a big difference
between me and Kevin.
Yeah,
I'll probably out‐sell her.
No.
Last year we did
$1.1 million in revenues.
What?
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
If you don't see the value,
I should go out.
No, don't say that.
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
John: You can say "No."
Counter.
Silence while I bring out
the genius of my offer.
[ Beep ]
Oh, my gosh...
[ Laughs ]
This is gonna be
so much fun.
I know.
Man:
Five, four, three, two...
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a duo with an accessory
to make high heels
more functional and comfortable.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Monica Ferguson.
And I'm Becca Brown.
And we're here today
to tell you about
our company Solemates.
We're seeking $500,000
in exchange for a 10% equity
stake in our business.
Wow. Whoo!
Brown: We have a product
that's changing the world
for women.
Women have a special
relationship with shoes,
especially high heels.
High heels make us taller,
longer, and leaner,
but these benefits
come at a high cost.
And we've all
been there ‐‐
You're at an outdoor wedding,
dressed to the nines,
when all of a sudden your heel
sinks into the grass.
Or you're walking down
a city street
in your favorite stilettos
when your heel gets stuck
in a sidewalk crack
or subway grate.
It's so annoying,
completely embarrassing,
and, not to mention,
ridiculously expensive,
ruining all those shoes.
The Solemates High Heeler
is a heel cap
that prevents high heels
from sinking into grass
and getting stuck
in cracks.
It works by
increasing the surface area
on the base of the heel,
which dissipates the pressure
and prevents the heel
from sinking or getting stuck.
Wearing Solemates
liberates women
to walk across any surface,
looking and feeling
her absolute best.
So, Sharks, which one of you
will be our soul mate?
Becca,
are you wearing them?
We both are.
We're both wearing them.
And we also have samples
to give you.
So you're wearing dark
to match your dark heel...
Ferguson: Yes.
Brown: Exactly.
Greiner: But you can snap on
a clear one.
Absolutely.
They come in clear, black,
silver, and gold.
Ferguson: Kevin?
Thank you.
Herjavec:
How much do they cost?
Each pair retails
for $10.
The box that you're holding
has three pairs in it
for three different sizes,
and that's $30.
$30 for this?
Greiner:
Can I see silver and gold?
Absolutely.
I'm just curious.
Your margins
must be incredible.
With the shoe.
Before we jump into
a lot of the specifics,
we'd love for you to try out
the product firsthand.
So, Lori, we actually have
a pair of heels for you.
Herjavec: Why Lori?!
Not to ‐‐
not to exclude ‐‐
Why ‐‐ Why Lori?
Why not me?
Brown: Not to exclude
the gentleman.
We invite you to come up,
as well.
Yeah.
Do you have my shoes my size?
Absolutely.
O'Leary: Robert ‐‐
Robert, get up there.
Well,
we have a pair for you.
Greiner: Oh, wow.
Ain't gonna happen.
Robert?
These are for you.
Which ones?
That one.
So,
Daymond and Robert ‐‐
No, actually,
this is Mark's size.
[ Laughs ]
Robert: One is ‐‐
Fall off and ‐‐
Fall off and break my ankle?
One has the product
and one doesn't.
Greiner: Oh, my God.
All right, Daymond!
Is that weird that I feel
very comfortable in these?
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: Yeah.
I think they're ‐‐
You wear them
really well.
[ Laughs ]
All right, try it.
So, now you're stepping
in the grass.
Greiner: Try it here.
The worst ‐‐ I'm sticking.
Ferguson: The one on the left
has it on,
the one on the right
does not.
Oh, so that's
how you try them.
Brown: You see?
Herjavec: Big difference.
Greiner: Do you feel it?
Huge difference.
Yeah, huge difference.
I ‐‐ I do feel
the difference.
Once you get used to
walking in heels...
Brown: Mark,
step up to the challenge?
...it's a huge difference.
That's okay.
O'Leary: This is not ‐‐
Brown: There you go.
This is not
a good thing for you.
This is a not a good look.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: I'm not sure
that helped your product.
What's your background?
Becca and I met, actually,
working at Goldman Sachs
right after college.
Uh, we there for several years
in different roles.
What happened?
[ Laughs ]
It was a great experience.
We learned a lot.
Genuinely, one of the reasons
that we're here today is
because one of the first things
we were taught there
was you're not expected
to know everything,
but you are expected to know
who to go to for everything.
And in this case, we're here
because you are who to go to.
I'm getting really excited,
'cause your in my space.
Brown: Yes.
You're in banking ‐‐
You know, I mean, in shares...
Oh, I thought high heels?
High heels?
...ETFs ‐‐
But I'm waiting to hear...
Kevin.
...how you're gonna take me
across into
the valuation metrics...
Yes.
... of this business,
which you're reputing
a $5 million valuation on.
Yes.
Bring it on, girls.
So, last year we did
$1.1 million in revenues.
What?
Wow. Really?
We're on track to do
$1.3 to $1.5 this year.
Herjavec: Hang on.
We've been in business
five years.
Yes?
O'Leary: Whoa.
How did you do $1. ‐‐
Where are you selling?
In my wildest dreams,
I didn't think
you had done $1 million.
We're sold in about 3,000
retail doors in this country,
including Nordstrom,
DSW, David's Bridal.
Brown: This a product
that women a lot of times
don't know they need
until they're
sinking into the grass
and experiencing it
firsthand.
And when a woman finds out
that this product exists,
she has to have it.
She is
a lifetime customer.
Ferguson: Yes.
The next benefit we have,
is that we are highly correlated
to the wedding industry
and the women's
shoe industry.
We sit right in the middle,
and when women see other women
wearing Solemates in the grass,
they say, "What is that?"
And then
they will order them
for their next wedding
or party.
But you're not making
any cash flow yet, are you?
We're not bec‐‐
We've broken even,
so our
gross profit margins ‐‐
Including paying yourself
something?
Yes.
65% gross profit margins ‐‐
How much
have you guys invested?
So, we, together,
invested $100,000
when we quit our jobs
at Goldman to start this.
And you've raised?
To date, we've raised
just under $1 million.
Wow.
Whoa.
How did you raise it?
Wow.
From angels ‐‐
friends.
Friends.
How many partners are there
in the business?
Monica and I both,
together, own 80%, 40/40.
Fantastic product.
Thank you.
The challenge is ‐‐
Your sales
will really go boom
the more convenient
the product is to buy.
Yes.
So, do you sell it to ‐‐
who?
The hotels,
the wedding planner ‐‐
Everywhere ‐‐
Hotel gift shops,
wedding planners, boutiques.
You have to be
everywhere.
We sell to venues,
we sell to hotels,
but it's fragmented
right now.
I mean,
how do you blow that up?
Do you have to find
a distributor that
sells that stuff,
or do you just need to hire
a team of people?
Bandwidth ‐‐
it's a bandwidth issue.
It's the two of us,
and we have one
full‐time person.
And what does
the full‐time person do?
She's our operations manager,
office manager.
Cuban: Guys, something's
not adding up for me though.
You've got, um, 65% margins
against $1 million in sales.
So you've got $650,000
in gross margin dollars.
There's only three of you.
Where's it going?
We work with
third‐party employers,
so we have a ‐‐
our graphics designers,
photographers,
web developers.
What was
your net profit?
$30,000.
How much did you pay
yourself?
Last year,
$80,000 each.
Each?
Okay.
Well, there you go.
So, $160,000 ‐‐
So, now I get it.
Greiner:
To me, the problem is
it's not something that people
need or need badly.
I don't know if I agree.
Because when you ‐‐
Well, you don't wear
high heels.
He does now.
[ Laughs ]
Uh, there's only
a certain amount of women
that wear
spiky high heels.
Mm‐hmm.
And they're a lot that
will only wear flats,
wedges, et cetera,
'cause they are
more comfortable,
and they're more stable.
But they're occasions
when you want to wear
a stiletto...
No, of course.
... and the product
acts like
an insurance policy
on that shoe.
If you're spending
$100 on a pair of shoes
or $1,000
on a pair of shoes,
you don't
want to ruin them.
I'm not saying
it's not a problem.
I'm just wondering how big
a problem for women is it?
For me, this isn't
the right investment...
Yeah.
So, I'm out.
Okay.
The numbers
don't add up for me,
and that's
part of the problem.
$5 million valuation,
10%, right, $500,000 ‐‐
In order for me
to get that back,
you got to make $5 million
in profits, right?
I don't see how you guys
are gonna get to
$50 million in sales.
That's my problem.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Appreciate that.
We believe
in this business.
We are committed to it.
We would never have quit
our jobs if we were not.
While we're doing
just over $1 million in sales,
we know we can do
$20 million, $30 million,
$40 million,
$50 million in sales.
John: So ‐‐ So, let's say
you're gonna go up to
$50 million in sales.
Uh, the net's
not gonna be the same.
There's gonna be
a lot of R&D.
Right.
There's gonna be
a lot of expansion in there,
and you're gonna have
to put a lot of money
back in the business.
You literally would have to do
$5 million a year...
In profits.
... 10 years,
and then maybe I would, uh,
make back just my investment,
no profit.
I don't even think we're gonna
have grass at that time.
So, uh, for that reason,
I'm out.
Herjavec:
Ladies, I think women
may not have been built
to wear stilettos,
but any product that makes
a man or a woman look good
and is comfortable
is a home run.
I mean, to me,
you're creating
a brand‐new category.
It ‐‐ It's kind of like
a SPANX.
It didn't exist.
I know
it's a wider category,
but I love the idea,
and your sales
prove themselves.
You need a team,
you need more people.
Your costs
are actually gonna rise.
I mean,
it's a long preamble to tell you
I'm gonna give you an offer
that you may not like,
but that's okay,
'cause I like it.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out,
but Robert seems interested in
Monica and Becca's shoe
accessory company Solemates.
I believe
in the two of you,
but $500,000 for 10%
is just nuts.
I'll give you $500,000
for 25%.
You're either
gonna get acquired
and you're gonna create
a brand‐new category.
And the only way I'm ever
gonna get the $500,000 back
is to help you scale this thing
to substantial size.
So, there's only
one person left.
O'Leary: Yeah.
What are you doing?
I'm ‐‐ I'm probably ‐‐
I sell a lot of products
to women.
I sell a lot products ‐‐
in the celebration times
we do everything.
I'm really struggling
with this.
And I like it. I like it.
All right, Kevin.
I can actually see
selling a lot of it.
Go ahead ‐‐ $2 per pack?
I might change the structure
a little bit...
Are you writing
another book?
because...
There you go.
Here we go. Here we go.
The ‐‐ The equity ‐‐
Royalty.
Let me finish.
Silence while I bring out
the genius of my offer,
and learn something
from it.
Here comes the deal.
Whatever.
This is important.
I'll give you 100K for 10%,
and I'll loan the business
$400,000,
'cause I think the business
is only worth a million
bucks right now.
Herjavec:
You're saying the business
is only worth $1 million today?
That's what I just said.
That's what I think it's worth.
With all due respect,
Kevin's offer's crazy.
When you're this small,
to take on
that amount of debt
and try to service it,
It ‐‐
Robert, would you be willing
to go to 20%?
Really?
5% is gonna make a difference?
It does make a difference
to us.
Why? Explain to me why.
I don't ‐‐
In order for us to maintain
a slight majority...
Cuban: Right.
... cumulatively,
20% would be
more meaningful to us.
Because they only own
80% right now.
Got it.
♪♪
Okay, I'll make it
more interesting for you.
Just so ‐‐
All right.
I'll do that deal.
Before you go ‐‐
Cuban: Done.
Okay.
Let me throw one out
just before ‐‐
Done?
Yes or no?
They said yes!
Just before you agree ‐‐
Do we have a deal?
Greiner:
Will you listen to him?
It's over.
Do we have a deal
or not?
Go shake hands.
Just before ‐‐
Greiner:
Are you listening?
Cuban: It's over!
John: Robert, go!
$500,000 for 20%.
♪♪
Yes.
I do.
Herjavec: All right.
John: Thank you.
Cuban: All right,
there you go.
You never heard
the second offer.
Thank you!
Thanks, guys.
That was great.
Thank you.
You did a good job.
We were curious
to hear your offer.
It wasn't ‐‐
Don't worry about him.
I just ‐‐ I just turn
your volume off.
Kevin,
you're dead to us.
Oh, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: Thank you, ladies.
Great job.
Thank you.
Cuban: Thanks, guys.
You've been really fun.
Congrats.
Good luck.
Bye bye.
♪♪
Something
that, um, Robert said,
which I think
really hit home with me,
was when he said
"You have created a category."
Yes.
And that is something
we often say ourselves,
and it's true.
We have created
the category.
This did not exist.
He got it.
And for him to pick up on that
meant a lot for us.
I think it's a lot.
Greiner: I think it's
a little bit tough.
This business isn't worth
more than a million bucks.
Yeah.
I would have went 30%.
It's a little bit tough,
yeah.
But listen, good luck.
Kevin, you're turning green
with envy.
Not really.
I would have done
the debt deal.
I really would have.
Of course you would have.
Narrator: In season six,
Army captain Ashley Drake
landed a deal
with Robert Herjavec
for her alternative
to weightlifting gloves ‐‐
The Natural Grip.
$125,000 for 25%.
I feel like Robert
can help me get there.
Narrator:
Let's see what she's up to now.
♪♪
Drake:
I'm here in Carson, California,
at the 2016 CrossFit games,
and we've been selected
as the preferred hand protection
for all of the athletes.
Let's go, Sam!
CrossFit
is functional fitness.
They're doing Olympic lifts,
they're climbing ropes,
they're doing pull‐ups,
and they are
the elite of the elite.
Now, why haven't you
hired sales guys?
Why am I telling you something
you already know?
Last time I met with Robert,
we had a heart‐to‐heart,
and he talked to me about
increasing the sales staff.
You know you need to do this.
You know it.
I immediately went to work.
All right, guys.
We're gonna have
a great day today.
Everybody knows their job.
We've grown from
6 employees to 25.
They're out there
gaining accounts,
and it couldn't
be going better.
Y'all want
to try them out?
Yes, please.
All right, great.
We now have
a licensing deal with CrossFit
and distribution deals set up
with Rogue Fitness and Reebok.
These the powerhouses
in our industry.
Before "Shark Tank,"
we had done $178,000 in sales.
Now we've done $1.5 million.
[ Beeps ]
I have one year left
to serve my country,
and I'm very proud
that I've had the opportunity
to be an Army Officer,
but it's time for me
to move on
and to make sure
that The Natural Grip
can be the best
that we can be.
It's been a long journey
to get here.
I just feel like
I'm living the American dream.
I could not be more proud
to be part of all of this.
All: One, two, three ‐‐
Natural Fit!
♪♪
My name is Jared Whetstone.
I'm from St. Augustine, Florida,
the oldest city
in the United States,
and my company
is Atlantic Candy Company.
How's it running?
Man: It's running good.
All right, man.
I'm a third‐generation
chocolatier.
My grandparents started
selling chocolate and ice cream
to tourists in the 1960s.
They opened up a store
which eventually became
a chocolate factory.
Yeah, these cells
are working a lot better now.
Whetstone:
Our factory makes products
for some of the biggest names
in the candy industry,
but we want to own our brands
and create our own products.
The assembly right here
and the top robot here.
My dad created and patented
a manufacturing technique
to make a popular candy product
that's sold all over the world.
It just hasn't been introduced
in the United States.
There's a lot at stake here.
For me, this is personal.
I've seen
how hard my dad's worked,
and I'm determined
to help him succeed.
I'm pitching on my own,
because my dad has to stay
back home and run the factory.
He's pretty busy.
But I'm pretty confident
that I'll go in there
and do a good job
and make him proud.
♪♪
Hey, boys and girls.
I'm Jared Whetstone
from St. Augustine, Florida,
and I'm here today
with the Atlantic Candy Company
seeking $1 million
in exchange ‐‐
In exchange for 10%
of my company.
♪♪
Sharks, we're taking toys
to a place that
they've never gone before ‐‐
the candy aisle.
Basically, these are
hollow chocolate articles
that contain
a surprise toy inside.
They are insanely popular.
There's over two billion
of these sold a year.
The best part about this product
is you don't know
what you're gonna get.
It's like your birthday
every time you open one.
[ Exhales sharply ]
♪♪
Sadly, these types of products
have been banned
in the United States
since the 1930s,
until recently.
But don't worry, Sharks.
This is America,
the land of innovation,
and my father
overcame this ban.
I'm a third‐generation
chocolatier...
You're good.
Good job.
I'm a third‐generation
chocolatier...
[ Exhales sharply ]
[BLEEP]
My father invented the first,
safe and legal solution
for this type of product,
specifically designed
for the U. S. market.
We are seeking a Shark
to partner with,
so that we can own
this product category
in the United States.
So, which one of you Sharks
wants to make a lot of money,
and take a big old bite
out of the U. S. candy industry?
Can we try it, Jared?
O'Leary:
Show us what they are.
Absolutely.
Of course you're
giving samples, right?
I assume it comes
in lots of flavors.
It does.
The one
you're about to taste is, uh ‐‐
has a tint of orange,
hope you don't mind.
And I'm gonna grab one
for Lori.
I like chocolate
in the morning.
Okay, thank you so much.
There you go, Lori.
Mr. Wonderful.
Herjavec:
I like the packaging.
Very cute packaging.
Yeah. I love that.
Thanks, Jared.
Appreciate it, buddy.
Whetstone: These are special
"Shark Tank" edition ‐‐
Herjavec:
Ooh, these are cool.
Ahh! Oh!
Look what came in mine!
There's six Sharks
to collect ‐‐
I got a Kevin!
John: I got a Robert.
Cuban: I got a Daymond.
I got a Lori.
This is just the ‐‐
to symbolize the type of toy ‐‐
But we can coincide with ‐‐
O'Leary: W‐‐ Why was it illegal
to put a toy in a chocolate?
Whetstone:
Okay, back in the 1930s,
a company in the U. S.
thought it was a good idea
to put metal toys
in solid‐milk chocolate bars
for kids to find, right?
Right. Yeah. Oh.
And kids were
cracking their teeth
and choking on them, right?
Well, how does Kinder Egg
get around it?
Okay, they're legal
in every other country
in the world, right,
except the United States.
They're, um ‐‐
Are you saying
Kinder Eggs
aren't sold
in the states?
They're not.
In Germany...
and everywhere else.
In Canada.
They're in ‐‐ They're in
every other country in the world
except the United States.
Why is that good news?
Why are we
going to get around the FDA
when Kinder Eggs,
the number‐one player can't?
Okay, my father
invented and patented
that capsule
you're holding in your hand.
Yes. Got it.
That capsule,
if you look at it,
that ridged design
complies with the FDA.
The FDA bans non‐nutritive items
from being embedded in food.
This capsule design
is not embedded.
As you noticed
when you unwrapped it,
the two
chocolate halves...
Right?
...came together,
but it never actually touches.
Okay.
So, Jared...
Clever.
... Let's say
that's all correct,
and it's an exciting
opportunity you had.
I give you
a $1 million for 10%
impugning
a $10 million valuation
and your sales today are?
Last year,
they were $2.5 million.
Yeah.
Oh.
Where are you selling?
Okay,
so it's important to note
that we have been
contract manufacturers.
For example,
this Australian company,
they approached my father
and licensed
his patented capsule design
to manufacture
these types of products
for sale in the U. S.
The 10‐year
manufacturing agreement
with the Australian company
terminated
December 31st of last year.
We are free to manufacture
this type of product.
But here's the deal ‐‐
There's only two years
of patent life
left on this patent.
Whoa.
Ohh.
So, now you're
looking for capital
to help you go
after this market.
Yes.
Except they'll be lots
of competition in 24 months?
Right, that's why speed ‐‐
That's why speed
to market's important.
O'Leary:
So when I think about it
as an investor,
holiday is a big time
for chocolates ‐‐
Easter, Hanukkah,
Christmas.
Sure.
Those are the times
of which there's only
one or two cycles left of that.
Why would anybody
value this at $10 million
if they've got 18 months
to cash in on it?
It is unusual.
So, Jared, the $2.5 million
you did last year,
the substantial part of that
was from this one licensee?
Yes.
But they're
gone now.
They're gone.
So you won't do
$2.5 million this year,
and your patent runs out
in about 20 months.
Absolutely.
So, we have immediate
production capacity
of 18 million units a year
at our factory
in St. Augustine, Florida.
Do you own a factory?
Yes.
We've got machines
on order.
This time next year,
we're ‐‐
We're planning to have
over 100 million units
of capacity.
Why are you ‐‐
Why are you expanding?
Uh, we believe in
this product category,
and we are ‐‐
We are going to compete
with this
product category.
Okay, so how much do you
expect to do in sales?
$3.3 million in sales
this year.
But, Jared,
how are you increasing
when you lost many of
your sales last year?
We ‐‐ We have existing ‐‐
We still have existing
contract manufacturing
with other companies.
Are you only talking about
this type of product,
or you're ‐‐ You're giving us
the entire number
that your company does
from regular chocolate bars,
everything else?
Total. Total.
Do you do regular?
Right ‐‐
So our niche is that
we have been known
throughout the industry
as manufacturers
of complex chocolate articles.
Okay?
L‐Let me explain.
Let me help.
Jared, let me help.
So ‐‐
Well, would you want
to get up there
and actually give
his presentation for him?
Atlantic Candy is
a contract manufacturer, right,
of chocolate items.
Yes, sir.
Your projection is to do
$3.3 million in sales
as a contract manufacturer.
Now, you have
this opportunity over here,
so if you were
looking for capital
and Shark expertise to rush it
to market, because ‐‐
To it's ‐‐
To exploit the category.
♪♪
Jared, I ‐‐ I see
what you're doing here,
and it's admirable.
The problem for me,
as an investor,
is you have to rush.
I don't know the contract
manufacturing business,
plus going out
and selling to the retailers.
I'd have to learn.
And in a rush scenario
like this,
I don't think
it'd be a good fit.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
So, here's
how I feel about it ‐‐
I, um ‐‐
My biggest challenge is
that you've never
serviced retail,
and it's a totally
different game.
When you're dealing
with retailers,
you are basically
at their mercy.
They're gonna test goods,
then you're gonna have
to be compliant, then ‐‐
They're gonna also leverage you
against other people
and see who else can come up
with a better price,
and because you
don't have years of
that experience,
I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
You know, you have a patent
that's about to run out,
so anybody else can do it.
I'm concerned
about the fact
that you only have
a handful of months left.
I'm out.
Thank you.
♪♪
Lead times in retail
are really long.
You actually
don't have 20 months.
To order for Christmas,
you're probably ordering,
when, Daymond?
A year and, uh ‐‐
Maybe a year and a half
earlier.
You need a sales force.
You need a game plan.
I'm out.
I understand.
Uh, the value of
a company like yours ‐‐
If it already
had a distribution system ‐‐
You know, if it had sales force,
had relationships,
would be somewhere between
five and seven times
after tax cash.
O'Leary:
So, you're pricing it right now
with the all the risk of
building that infrastructure...
At 10%
that's not in place yet,
at a very high multiple.
I'm sorry, Jared.
I ‐‐ I have no interest in going
on the journey with you.
I'm out.
I understand. Thank you.
♪♪
This is my first pitch.
It's probably my biggest.
Wow.
You know,
this is, um...
You bounced back.
Thank you, guys.
Good luck, Jared.
Thanks, guys.
Greiner:
Good luck, Jared.
We're rooting for you.
♪♪
It's a lot different
when you're saying
it in your head
versus when you got the "Lights,
camera, action," on you.
I just got ‐‐ I just got
completely knocked off course.
Like, went in there
with a game plan and...
it all just went to pieces.
It was a disaster.
♪♪
Narrator: Next in the Tank
is a brand‐new innovation
for the kitchen.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Doug Foreman.
I'm from Austin, Texas.
I'm seeking $500,000
for 5% equity of my company.
Now, Sharks,
if you love cooking, eating,
and entertaining like I do,
then you probably love
using real butter.
But the problem with butter
is it's hard and cold.
It tears up toast,
or if you're cooking with it,
your burn it in the pan.
Melted butter
and pouring it popcorn ‐‐
That's just a soggy mess.
Sharks, I'd like
to introduce to you
the first and only spray
that uses real butter
and goes from butter stick
to butter spray
in just a few seconds.
It's called Biem.
Just insert
a stick of butter,
and using just heat and air
without chemicals
or artificial ingredients,
you're ready to Biem.
You can Biem pans
for a healthier, tastier,
nonstick cooking spray.
You can Biem bread or rolls.
You can Biem corn on the cob
or popcorn.
Anything you can butter,
you can Biem.
So, which one of you
is ready to join us
and help us to make the world
a "butter" place.
[ Laughs ]
Herjavec: Yeah.
I've got some to show you.
Oh, you do?
Yeah.
And bring that popcorn
over.
I have to give Lori's hers,
'cause she's little.
Yes.
Thank you.
She can't reach it.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Foreman: We actually have
a motion detector
so that as soon as
you lift it up,
it's gonna turn itself on
and start.
Oh, wow.
Greiner:
So, by lifting it...
Foreman: Right.
... the heat
starts to work.
Yes.
It melts the butter.
Right. And it ‐‐ It only melts
the butter that you need.
Not ‐‐
It doesn't keep melting.
This thing does
more than my car.
How did you come up
with this idea,
and give us a little bit
about your history.
Well, um ‐‐
So I've been in the food
business most of my life.
I started a company in 1989
called Guiltless Gourmet.
It was the first
baked tortilla chip
in the United States.
Oh, I love those.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I sold that company.
You had a good exit?
Had a good exit.
Uh, got married, had kids,
and had an exit there, too.
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
What ‐‐ What price point
are you gonna sell them at?
We sold those
at an average of $137.
Ow‐che‐wawa.
O'Leary: $137.
$137.
What did they cost you
to make?
Foreman:
Right now it's at $43,
but we're also, you know,
working it down.
Is it patented?
It's patent pending.
Yes, both utility
and design.
Utility?
What's the ‐‐
what's the ‐‐
Is there anybody else
that has melting spray?
No.
You must have a sense of
how large the market is
when you're saying
today it's worth $10 million.
Yeah.
What's your plan
to work your way
into that valuation?
The cooking spray market
right now in the United States
is about $375 million.
We plan to go direct to consumer
first online.
Online.
So, what do you think
in terms of numbers
in the next
three to five years?
We think that next year,
we can probably sell
100,000 units.
So, you're thinking
$10 million next year.
Yeah.
♪♪
Here ‐‐ Here's my issue.
Yeah.
You're very successful.
You know that
you wouldn't do this
at 5% yourself probably,
right?
I know that you offered
everybody else
at that valuation,
but you know the advantage
of coming here.
So, why are we
at 5% right now?
Because you haven't
given me an offer otherwise.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec:
Because he's a smart guy.
I'll give you an offer.
♪♪
I'll give you the $500,000
for...
17.5%.
Oh!
Herjavec: Okay.
It's an offer.
Have you ever had
any problems with it, any kinks?
Well, you know, prototypes
that are put together
and taken apart
a bunch of times ‐‐
I mean, obviously,
I've had a lot of those ‐‐
Doug, you're pretty savvy,
right?
Yeah.
You came in here, you ‐‐
Wait, wait.
I want to hear the answer.
You probably know who you
want to be partners with.
Well, I want an answer,
too, which ‐‐ I have
an offer on the table.
No, I want to know
if he's having issues
with it clogging, or ‐‐
I think
all that's crap, Lori.
Lori,
I think all that is crap.
You're as real as it gets,
a proven entrepreneur.
You're coming back
to where you have experience,
you know how to get this stuff
out there,
and You got a potential
amazing partner right here
at 17.5%.
Yep.
I've got a lot of customers
in the wine business
and a ton in the food business
that I've sold all direct,
didn't use retail to do it.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
I'll do the $500,000
for 15%.
I'll undercut Daymond
a little bit,
primarily 'cause
I think I can sell it
directly to
my customer base now.
So, you're giving him
a $3.5 million value.
I ‐‐ I think
that's worth it.
I'll match
Kevin O'Leary's offer.
So, Doug, I ‐‐ I just have
a question around in the ‐‐
Doug, you have two offers
on the table.
Herjavec: Is there a feature
from the product that
we can we take away
in a model
and come out at
a significantly
lower price point?
Probably the ‐‐
the outer shell,
'cause we're using
stainless.
Greiner: You could have
a cheaper model,
and you could have
your higher‐end luxury model.
Exactly.
Are you open
to that?
Yes.
Can it be
substantially less
if you did it
in a different material?
Yes.
All right, well, I'm gonna
tell you what I think.
Can I get an answer
to my offer?
I think
you hit my trifecta,
which is "Clever,"
"Unique,"
and let's just say
tres magnifique.
Foreman: Thank you.
I like that you have
a great product,
but you also have skill,
and you're an innovator,
and you're willing to work.
Yes.
So, I'm gonna
make you an offer.
I'm gonna offer you
$600,000...
for 20%.
♪♪
I mean, this is what I do ‐‐
I manufacture products.
So, to me ‐‐
You're giving him
even lower value
than Daymond and Kevin.
Okay, so, why would you
give up more equity?
That offer's
worse than ours.
It is worse.
O'Leary: Yeah.
♪♪
I'll give you the $500,000
for 10%.
♪♪
Thank you, Robert.
I've seen this before
when Sharks have offers
and you're not
talking to them.
It starts to get
really nasty.
And these offers ‐‐
They start to disappear.
♪♪
Narrator:
All five Sharks are still in,
and Doug has four offers
for his butter spray company
Biem.
I've seen this before
when two or three Sharks
have offers
and you're not
talking to them.
They start to disappear.
It's starts to get
really nasty,
and that's the last thing
you ever want to do
is not make somebody feel
like you're acknowledging ‐‐
Daymond,
I appreciate your offer.
I absolutely do.
What do you think
of our offers?
Cuban:
Well, he's obviously ‐‐
Look, he's obviously
valuing the company higher,
otherwise he would have
grabbed the offer.
He's not just ‐‐
So, then say no. Counter.
♪♪
Mark, are you gonna
make an offer?
Yeah, what I'm trying
to figure out, Doug,
is what you truly value.
Right.
Because you got,
you know,
20%, 15%, and 10%,
and you haven't jumped
or haven't countered
on any of that.
There has to be something,
because you have to assign
a value to us.
Obviously.
I mean, look,
there's a reason I'm here.
What is it that you're
actually looking for?
It's a big difference between
if I call a Williams‐Sonoma,
or they call me.
But a Shark can call
Williams‐Sonoma
and get you right in.
But I'm not gonna ‐‐
I'm not gonna be that
Shark to do it,
because I'm starting
to be concerned about
how you would be
as a partner.
So, I'm gonna take my offer
off the table.
Whoa.
Sorry to hear that.
I like people
who are deceive.
Greiner: When you were
laying in bed last night,
what were you thinking
you wanted to have
happen here today?
To do a deal.
With?
You know, I know Mark,
you know, your background
and the companies
that you have, uh,
for ‐‐ as far as infrastructure
and setting it up ‐‐
e‐commerce stuff that ‐‐
It was something that
was very attractive to me.
I don't have that?
What I heard Doug say
is he wants to do a deal
with Mark Cuban.
I want to be a partnership.
I want to be in it with you.
And I ‐‐ And I ‐‐
And I do, too.
You want to do it with Mark.
I'm out.
♪♪
John: Doug, you see
what I kind of predicted
that was gonna happen?
You better hurry up
and get to negotiating.
Well, I didn't hear Cuban.
Is he in or out?
What I see is
a product that's cool,
product that, more importantly,
you have complete confidence in,
but not every business
is a fit for me.
I just don't see it.
I'm out.
Thanks.
O'Leary: Well, this is
getting interesting.
You've got
two offers left.
Yes.
Yet you had a lot more interest
just a few minutes ago.
The real question is,
are you willing to part
with more than 5% equity
for any Shark?
Yes.
Okay.
So, the question is,
how much more than 5%?
Those offers multiplied.
You know,
I'd like to hear a counter.
Would you do ‐‐
Would you match
Kevin's deal?
Would I match
were Kevin is at?
Of course.
Do you not want to do
a deal with Kevin?
You asked Lori
to match Kevin's offer.
Oh, I ‐‐ I was ‐‐
If you're willing
to take that offer,
why not just take
Kevin's offer?
Because there's a big difference
between me and Kevin.
Yeah.
I'll probably outsell her.
No.
Now, just for fun,
$500,000 for 14%.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
You know, my attitude is
I look at this thing and say
"There is a lot of work."
But primarily,
my focus is to sell the product
to my existing base
of people
that already trust me
to buy food product.
That's basically it.
Greiner:
I'm about sales.
I have all the resources.
I've manufactured
over 500 products.
The thing that
I'm sitting here wondering is
if you don't see the value
in what I can do,
and that doesn't
get you excited
and you don't want
to make a deal,
then my feeling is
I should go out.
Lori, let's do a deal.
Oh, my God. Good.
Thank you.
Are you excited?
Yes, thank you!
I need excitement from you.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Appreciate it.
All right, good.
All right.
Well, we'll sell
some butter spray.
Congratulations, Doug.
Great job.
Appreciate it.
See you in Austin.
Thanks.
I guess.
Foreman:
I feel great about about
having the deal with Lori.
She's right up my alley
for how to get done at retail
and to sell a product.
And, you know, we're ‐‐
We're gonna do great
things together.
God, please let us
all be okay.
Please let us walk away
with a great deal.
Please help us
be energetic.
Please help everybody
be nice.
And, God, please don't
let us mess up. Amen.
♪♪
NARRATOR: Next up is a product
made especially for tweens.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Madison,
and I'm 12.
Hi, I'm Mallory,
and I'm 10.
Hello,
I'm their mom Viara.
We are seeking $55,000
in exchange for
20% of our company.
We created a body‐care line
for tween and teen girls,
made by
tween and teen girls.
We have yummy scents
and funny names
like Watermelon Funk
and Frozen Hot Chocolate.
We believe that when you
smell good, you feel good.
I know that you'll like
our body sprays.
And I know that
you'll like our lotions.
♪ I know that you'll like
the way that I smell ♪
♪ This ain't no secret,
'cause I'm gonna tell ♪
[ Laughs ]
♪ Angels and tomboys ♪
John: Whoo!
Wow!
Nice.
♪ This Watermelon Funk ♪
♪ Got me smelling
some type of way ♪
[ Laughs ]
♪ Can't go a day ♪
♪ Day ♪
♪ Without that body spray ♪
♪ Girl, I love the smell ♪
♪ Got everybody talkin' ♪
♪ My sister right beside me ♪
♪ Smells Frozen Hot Chocolate ♪
♪ No lie, no lie ♪
♪ It's online, it's online ♪
♪ So go buy, go buy ♪
♪ Angels and Tomboys ♪
All: All girls are created
equally different.
Greiner: Yay.
Herjavec:
Yeah! Great job.
Now, we have samples
for you to enjoy.
[ Laughter ]
Let's smell it.
[ Laughs ]
Madison, you look so
different in the video.
[ Giggles ]
See,
we have Candy Star Glam.
Herjavec:
There you go, Lori.
Thank you.
You have Candy Star Glam
body spray,
and you have Frozen Hot
Chocolate body spray.
Herjavec: Oh, okay.
O'Leary: Thank you.
Madison: You have
Lemonade Doughnuts.
Greiner: Mm.
Thanks.
You have
Watermelon Funk.
Thank you.
But of course.
O'Leary:
Let me try yours, Lori.
It smells very good.
Thank you.
O'Leary: Let me try yours.
His Lemonade Doughnut
smells really good, too.
Lemonade Doughnuts.
Madison: Hope you enjoy.
So, ladies,
this is the product line.
It's a body spray
for kids.
Right now, there's body sprays
and body lotions
to kind of introduce the brand
to the marketplace.
However, it is our goal
later on down the line
to have a full‐fledged
personal hygiene company.
How much
do you sell it for?
We sell it for $12.
That seems like a lot to me.
Is that a lot?
You think about the ingredients
that are involved,
Viara: They're ‐‐ they're
all‐natural ingredients.
I like that.
So, they're made with vitamins
A, C, and E,
the whole paraben‐free,
vegan‐friendly concept, so...
What is cost you to make,
and how do you sell it?
Cost to make?
Mallory: $4.
And how do you sell it?
We sell online
and at trade shows.
They sell at trade shows?
How many have you sold?
If you sell at trade shows,
you sell ‐‐
We ‐‐ We sell 5,000.
So, have you sold
$5,000 worth, or ‐‐ or ‐‐
No, we sell 5,000 units.
We've sold $59,000 worth.
Yeah! That's good.
Wow.
Viara: Yes, absolutely.
Greiner: $59,000?
So you guys are
making money then.
Wait, wait, wait, Kevin.
You guys are profitable,
then, right?
Uh, we're not as profitable
as we can be.
So how are you acquiring
customers online?
How would anybody
know about you right now?
We are word of mouth.
We are social media,
all day long,
every day pushing
the brand online.
And we did
a lot of street footwork,
guerrilla marketing.
The girls were even
taking product to schools
in their backpack
and selling it.
Selling.
But what made you
even think of the idea?
Yeah, tell him what made
you think of it.
We ‐‐ [ Laughs ]
We were always playing
with our mom's lotions,
but they all are...
[ Laughs ]
Both:
Too flowery, too strong,
or too expensive.
[ Laughs ]
And, like, we just kind of
wanted our own thing.
Like, literally,
there's nothing out there ‐‐
Either Victoria's Secret ‐‐
like what little girl our age
feels comfortable
going into Victoria's Secret?
Especially the parents ‐‐
uncomfortable.
It's okay,
but it's not really for us.
It's an interesting
demographic.
You're talking about kids
that are sort of 5 to 11,
is that it?
12, uh‐huh.
Okay, so that's
the target market?
5 to 12.
Where, exactly,
would you put that?
What retailer
would you optimize in?
Target would be ‐‐
How big can this be?
What ‐‐ Like,
what's equivalent product?
Well, there isn't one,
to be honest with you.
However, this is
a trillion‐dollar market.
You're talking about ‐‐
Trillion?
Are you familiar with, like,
the girls product line
with lip glosses,
the body sprays,
the lotions, the perfumes?
Little girls
want to smell good,
I mean, all day, everyday.
The girls are using it up.
They run through like water.
So, listen,
your scents are very good.
They smell great.
Thank you.
I wear a perfume that's actually
called "Sugar" sometimes.
Or "Chocolate."
People are like,
"What are you wearing?
I love that smell."
I'm like,
"It's 'Chocolate'"
But, you know what,
chocolate smells good.
Absolutely.
So, um...
Thank you.
Greiner: I think ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my.
Oh.
I was thinking out loud.
Sorry.
I'm speechless.
I love it.
The question is,
isn't there in drugs stores
and in Target
and that, like, sweet smelling,
fun little bottles of scents
for girls?
We've gone to the stores.
We've done the research.
We've been online.
But, this ‐‐
But isn't that ‐‐
But there's not just
lip balm.
We haven't got ‐‐
But what about lotions?
Why wouldn't, in ‐‐
in the fragrance category,
which is very high‐margin
business ‐‐
If they thought there
was a real category for
5 to 12 year olds,
they would populate it
with products.
They just
haven't done it.
O'Leary: I know, but ‐‐
I mean,
but, everybody ‐‐
Yeah, yeah, no.
Somebody's got to be first!
Everybody has to create
something.
Somebody has to do it,
and we're doing it.
We have done it.
So, I mean,
the risk for an investor,
any investor, any Shark, is
maybe the reason
they haven't done it
is 'cause
there's no market.
Maybe they haven't
done it,
'cause they haven't thought of it.
No, that's, like,
saying anything ‐‐
Yeah. That's ‐‐
I mean, honestly,
it's as simple as that.
I want to talk
to Madison and Mallory.
Do you guys love
doing this?
Yes, very much.
Love.
Are you into it?
Like, are you having fun
running the business?
Yes.
Tell me about
what you guys do.
So much so
you're gonna quit school?
[ Laughs ]
No. Education
is still important.
Where are you making
the product?
At home.
Oh, you're packaging
it at your kitchen
table, literally.
Yes.
Wow.
Who was the genius
that created
the "All girls are created
equally different"?
Ah!
Cuban: Ta‐da!
You?
Every ‐‐ Every ‐‐
Good girls.
It's a very smart
branding statement.
That's a great line.
And where did
the name come from?
Um, well,
I'm sort of the angel.
Angel.
And she's the tomboy.
Tomboy.
[ Laughs ]
Aww.
Madison: Yeah.
O'Leary:
So, if you got a retail order
for 100,000 units,
who would make it?
You can't do that
on your kitchen table.
Well, I've already
spoken to manufacturers,
and they've ‐‐
And you've gone over
the numbers
on how much
they would actually ‐‐
Right, so it wouldn't cost us
$4 if we had a manufacturer.
We'd be looking closer
to $1.75.
Herjavec: Viara let me ‐‐
Let me start it.
I ‐‐ I'm just struggling
with seeing a market for this
for girls between 5 to 12.
I'm not saying
there isn't one,
but, you know, I sit here,
I have to make a decision.
I don't see it. Like,
I wouldn't buy that for my kids.
I'm not saying
it's a bad product.
I ‐‐ I just don't see it.
I'm out. Thank you.
Viara: Thank you.
It's really intriguing,
'cause I don't think
this category exists.
That's the big risk,
I mean ‐‐
No,
that's the big upside.
Well,
it's not that easy a task.
I'm just, you know ‐‐
You girls should understand
the world's tough out there.
This is not
gonna be easy.
And I ‐‐ I ‐‐
You know, I'm just wondering
is it something
you have to create?
That's the ‐‐
People are buying it,
though.
That's the difference.
We put it in front of people,
they buy it.
I don't think
you've proven that yet.
That it can be sold?
Yeah.
It's absolutely a market.
I don't know,
I'm ‐‐ I'm looking at it
pragmatically ‐‐
I'm looking at
it pragmatically.
And you're looking at moms
and dads that buy.
I'm just saying,
you know, for me
the amount of work
that's gonna be required here
to get it into retail,
which is where it should sell,
too much risk for me.
I'm out.
Okay.
Sorry, ladies.
Well, first of all,
your song and dance
were great.
Herjavec:
The dancing was awesome.
You guys are
really super stars.
It's a very scary thing
to come into the Shark Tank,
and, really, the most
beautiful thing you're wearing
is your confidence.
Thank you.
I know how hard a path it is
with a fragrance.
I've already been in
the business with fragrances.
It was very tough.
A lot of celebrities
come out with fragrances.
They also have ‐‐
have not succeeded.
So, I'm out,
but you've done
a good job so far.
Thank you.
You know, I'm, um...
So, um ‐‐
It's tough, because...
What are you struggling with,
Daymond?
I'm struggling with ‐‐
Well, a couple of things,
you know?
You're torn.
I can see it.
Yeah, often people giving up
at this early stage ‐‐
You're contorting yourself
to take a hobby
and call it a business.
That's really
what's going on.
Yeah, but their ‐‐
Their hobby followed
the same exact path
as my hobby followed.
I got it.
So you got to ‐‐
You know, my hobby ‐‐
I went around to the trade shows
and sold shirts
and kept selling
and kept selling, kept selling.
Well, just be honest with them.
and tell them what it is.
It's a hobby.
Would it have been better
or worse for you, Daymond,
if someone
had given you a deal?
Absolutely.
Or you do you think you're
better off that nobody did?
No, don't say that.
[ Exhales sharply ]
My biggest challenge
is the fact that
after this is on somebody,
you can't see it.
You have to market it
dollar by dollar
and/or exposure P. R..
Mark and I were talking here,
and I was asking him,
you know,
if we can do an offer together,
because he has a history here
with Simple Sugars.
So, I think
if Mark is down with me,
uh, and we can
make an offer.
Uh...
Right now you're asking
$55,000 for 20%.
♪♪
$60,000 for 1/3?
Herjavec: Wow.
And that way you get
both Sharks.
So, you'd own 66%,
and we'd own the 1/3.
Yeah.
[ All whispering ]
♪♪
Daymond and I together ‐‐
What do you guys think?
Yeah, we good?
Mm‐hmm.
We're good.
We get two Sharks.
All right!
We got two Sharks.
Greiner:
Congratulations.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you, guys,
so much.
John: Absolutely.
Thank you.
John: Come on, team hug.
Cuban: Team hug.
There we go.
Get them all in.
You smell great.
[ Laughter ]
Wait.
Oh, wait a minute.
I just smelled
something really bad.
Oh, that was Mark.
No, I'm fine.
Don't worry. Killing me.
Thank you.
Let me see that little
moonwalk you got.
Mm.
Give me five.
Don't leave me hanging.
There you go.
Oh, wow,
that was really good!
Let's do it together.
Viara:
Oh, wow. Oh, wow!
[ Laughter ]
You're awful!
You need a little work,
Daymond.
All right, thank you.
Cuban: Good job, guys.
Thank you.
We appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Congrats, guys.
♪♪
[ Snapping fingers ]
Mallory: Hey!
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
So, I have my angel...
[ Laughs ]
... and I have my tomboy!
And they're different,
but they're equal,
and I love them so much.
I'm so proud of them,
and I just ‐‐
I want every girl in the world
to feel beautiful and to just be
proud of who they are.